hey what's up guys my name is the
channel welcome back to my game engine
series for the first time now being
streamed live on
twitch link will be in the description
below if you want to catch future live
streams
so last time we talked about the whole
camera system in fact
our whole journey so far has been with
the entity component system and we
talked about camera systems and how we
can integrate
cameras into our scenes and all that fun
stuff
check out that video if you haven't
already and today we're going to be
continuing on
a little bit with our camera system
because there are a few things that it
just does not support yet
such as resizing the viewport so without
further ado
let's dive on into our code and take a
look at what it is that we're going to
be doing today
so the main problem that we have here if
i just give this a quick build
is when we resize the viewport it just
doesn't really
like resize the camera so in other words
this little square that we have here
gets really squishy and in fact if i
um bring that back you can see did my
lights just turn off
thank you wife for turning off my lights
on
stream while recording a video all right
go
go
classic wife i was talking about this
square being squishy so if we resize
this obviously the square gets
squishy our goal for today is to make it
so that the square does not get squishy
because we ultimately want to resize the
aspect ratio of the camera if
that happens so the way that we need to
do that it's
like in general this whole problem is
pretty simple
but you know you know us making this
game engine series usually
we want to talk about the problem in a
broader sense as well as
talk about all the possible implications
of this problem
and this is going to be a perfect excuse
for us to actually jump in and take a
look at
you know how should cameras get resize
events should all cameras
in the whole scene get resized what
about the whole editor versus runtime
camera situation
there are so many things that we could
discuss and in fact
about half an hour before even starting
this episode i spent the last half hour
discussing this with with twitch chat
and planning this in general so
definitely a good discussion and
definitely a lot to be said
but i'm gonna now try and condense this
into this episode so ultimately
my and what we kind of came up with is
there are two types of cameras that we
have in our scene this is not counting
the whole editor
camera or you know anything like that
during a game's runtime there are
ultimately
you could divide cameras into two
different categories the cameras that
essentially should be rendering some
kind of view of the scene
that is directly tied to a final kind of
render output to our viewport or to our
actual screen
so in other words if i make a 1920x1080
game window and i'm playing my game
there
i want my camera to fill the screen if i
minimize this or like
rather i guess not minimize but make the
window smaller and maybe change the size
of the window
i want the window to basically be my
viewport into this
either 2d or 3d scene that is kind of a
viewport into my
game world that obviously should be tied
with the size of the window or your
viewport or your render area
the other type of camera that we have
though is something that doesn't
necessarily need to be tied to the
current viewport size
so a good example is maybe i have like
a tv in my game that's obviously always
going to be like a four by three aspect
ratio it's like an old school like tv
somewhere in the corner
and it's displaying an image which
happens to be a live render
of a different part of the scene that's
always going to be 4-3
you know i don't need to worry about the
aspect ratio there because it has
nothing to do
with the size of my game window as would
for example a shadow map if you were
rendering like a shadow map through a
camera which is an empty in your scene
for some reason then that will you might
decide that's fixed it's always going to
be a 10 24 by 10 24 shadow map so
therefore a one to one aspect ratio
that's not something that needs to
actually be changed
if i resize my window so in other words
we have two categories here
we have the kind of fixed aspect ratio
category
and then we have the not fixed aspect
ratio category and the non-fixed aspect
ratio category
is where all of our kind of i guess well
not all of our but our main camera
that's the category that it falls into
so what we're going to do is basically
into camera component we're going to add
a new boolean and it's going to be
called let me just zoom in for you guys
it's going to be called fixed aspect
ratio
equals false okay by default so what
that means is if you set
fixed aspect ratio to true and and this
will be like a checkbox that you can
actually check in the editor when you're
designing your game
then that means that the aspect ratio is
fixed meaning
it's not going to care if the main
viewport that you're rendering to
gets changed whereas if that is set to
false then it
you would expect the camera's uh
projection matrix to actually be updated
so um with that in mind uh we should now
be able to
inside edit the layer this is going to
be the next step
um editor layer has uh inside the on
update function it has the camera
controller on resize and well
you can see this is kind of the resize
area if the if the viewport size has
changed um and it's now like it's you
know whatever
we resize the frame buffer obviously we
also want to say that hey
active scene let's set the viewport size
to be something else right
so you could set the viewport size here
and i think i probably will
do that um but i'm actually uh
going to rename this and call it on
viewport resize
and we're going to chuck in this code
here
and these are what are these these are
floats technically um but i think i will
just make this
a uint 32t all right all right so we
have
um inside scene
we now have a function wow scene is
looking empty
on viewport resize you want 32 width
you went 32 height
um let's create an implementation for
that so i want to set viewport
width and height here so the reason i
want to do this is because they
might be useful later so i just want to
keep track of them
but to be honest i don't know if um
i don't know if we'll need that anytime
soon
so we'll initialize them to zero in case
we never get that event
uh viewport height equals zero
um and then here we want to resize
resize our non-fixed aspect
ratio cameras
so how do we do that this is really easy
we just need to basically
create a view this is called uh there
were some errors some people pointed out
some errors with what i
wrote which is to be expected um i don't
think there are really any errors here i
think i just call
i think i just accidentally called this
group
even though it's a view um do i have any
other
errors um
[Music]
i don't think so um all right so
we basically need to do the same thing
this actually is a group i think
we basically need to do the same thing
whereas
um we just we're just using one
component here so instead of doing like
multiple components here
we're going to just do the camera
component so we have a view into all of
the camera components in the scene
and now that we've done that we can do
view dots
[Music]
view dot get camera
components dot camera maybe um
and this will be our
camera um
[Music]
what did i do here
um review uh view entity view view all
right we need the entity okay
so we'll get the um camera here and then
we can now see if the camera has a
fixed uh oh wait sorry
this is this is what we want this is the
camera component
so if the camera component has a fixed
aspect ratio
right if it doesn't well if it does then
whatever if it doesn't
that's where we actually need to resize
it how do we resize it though
this is where it gets a little bit
tricky and this is kind of the next
phase of this
video so what
what do we need to change a camera's
aspect ratio
well realistically what the way that you
probably want to do this
is to recalculate the projection matrix
and to recalculate the projection matrix
you need to know how
to make that projection matrix so what
is all the source data that went into
making that projection matrix
so in other words um if we take a look
at
uh the way that we made this in the
first place which to be honest i don't
remember
it looks like we just created a like an
orthographic matrix here actually
um we said negative 16 blah blah we need
this same data here
to try and figure out how exactly to do
this now realistically this data that
we're looking at minus 16 16 -9 was very
very arbitrary
it was something i just made up because
i'm like okay well let's just
pump in a matrix it's not really how we
want to do things instead what we want
to do
is create a little bit more flexibility
and robustness
by saying that what we should do for an
orthographic camera
is just specify a size i mean especially
if it's fixed
aspect ratio we really just should have
a size so how big is this
is this orthographic camera like are we
dealing with like minus 10 to 10
minus 100 to 100 minus one to one you
know what is the size of this
orthographic camera
and usually um well i don't want to say
usually because people do this
differently
but we could say for example and i think
the way that i'm doing this inside hazel
dev
actually is i'm basically just saying
that
um uh
the width is going to be the
orthographic size
times that aspect ratio you so in other
words when we talk about
a um an orthographic camera size we're
talking about the
vertical field of view i guess field of
view is probably not the right term to
use because it's a perspective it's not
a perspective projection camera
it's an orthographic camera that's why
we kind of say size instead of
field of view because it's not a frustum
um but
uh that's going to be our vertical just
just the same way as fov
is usually vertical fog when we're
dealing with like graphics programming
so um because of that the height is
going to be our
view our orthographic size and then the
width is going to be our orthographic
size
times whatever the aspect ratio is
so for a 69 aspect ratio which is 1.78
we would have a 5 sorry not a 5. we
would have a width of
10 times well if our viewport size was
10
you know what viewport size times 1.78
so in other words if it was 10 we'd have
a like a viewport i guess width
of and again you probably want to also
because it's it goes from left to right
and also top to bottom it's not like
it's a
you know we have to kind of deal with
half extents here so you probably have
to multiply by 0.5
and then subtract one side and then add
the other side anyway we'll get into
this in a minute i don't know why i'm
explaining this
by waving my hands i should probably be
programming but anyway
um we ultimately would have like a uh
an orthographic width of about 17.8
and an orthographic height of 10. so
that's the calculation that i'm thinking
of doing here
how are we going to do this well we
could extend camera a little bit
but what i want to do because if you
think about it this camera is inside the
renderer folder
right it's clearly something that has to
do with the renderer itself it's not
some kind of like you know entity
component system like
uh level editor camera class
it's actually like to do with the
renderer so as far as the renderer is
concerned
i don't care about your orthographic
projection
just give me a matrix so i don't want to
modify this glass and add all that stuff
instead what i want to do
is to the scene class i want to add a
new
class and this is going to be our
scene camera and a scene camera is going
to include
hazel renderer camera
and it's going to uh basically derive
from that camera class so it's going to
include that matrix that we have
there
um and uh scene camera again you know we
probably don't need to worry
too much about this stuff in fact i
probably don't even need to have a
virtual destructor
no i'm kidding i should um
okay so we'll add that in what this is
going to be
is just a it's going to be a derived
version of the same camera which is
going to have a lot of
convenience functions as well as storing
the parameters that we use to make up
our camera so in the future we're
obviously going to support multiple
cameras when i support an orthographic
camera as well as a perspective
projection camera
this is what will have the type of
camera set in here
and this is what we're going to show in
the kind of
inspector panel i guess when we select
the camera entity so that we can see the
camera components
when we're actually drawing the ui to
the camera component that's where we can
obviously select if we want like a
perspective or an orthographic
projection
what that orthographic size is what the
perspective of stuff like that
so this is almost this class is almost a
representation of exactly what we will
see
in that ui so as such we need to store
that stuff so we're not going to worry
about like supporting both orthographic
and perspective at this point
but what i will have is i'll have an
orthographic size which by default will
be 10
and then i'll have an orthographic nia
i'm just calling everything like with
orthographic here just so that it's
clear what's perspective later on
um so orthographic near and orthographic
farm
which will be a positive one okay
that's basically what makes up um and i
guess just to keep this a little bit
neater i might put that on one line
this is what makes up our orthographic
camera if we have this
we should be able to reconstruct the
camera and that's what we'll be able to
do
so by creating a scene camera um
do i want some constructor arguments
maybe but honestly what i'm going to do
is just write a function here
called set orthographic which is going
to take in an orthographic size
a near clip and a far clip
far clip and then what this is going to
do let me just add a cpp file
what this is going to do is apart from
actually storing this in the member
variables it's also going to recalculate
that projection matrix so uh
that was a disaster let's include h as a
pc h
as well as sorry i zoomed out again i
always do that
um scene camera
let's quickly uh use visual assist here
to create
all of these um yeah we don't we don't
need
this
default let's get rid of that i'm not
even sure if we really need this
we'll see obviously it depends here um
and what's why is this so upset no
default constructed is for camera okay
that's fine um so we need we do need to
set a projection matrix to begin with
is that something i even want to deal
with though i'm not sure i do
i think that what we should do
potentially and i'm not exactly sure how
hmm okay let's do this let's in inside
this camera class let's add a default
constructor
so it's possible to create a camera
without a matrix now but we will make
sure that
we will actually like set this to be a
glm map for
um that's initialized to an identity
matrix if that's the case
that way we can create a scene camera
without anything and then you would
expect to call like set orthographic
on it and set orthographic this is kind
of the thing that's actually going to
um do uh orthographic size
equal size near orthographic mia equals
near clip
and then orthographic uh
orthographic far
equals far clip um i'll also add a
function into scene camera
called set viewport size so um 32
width uh 32 height so what this is
what this function is going to do is
based on whether or not this is an
orthographic or a perspective camera
it's actually going to
set up our matrix accordingly so
we have and if i jump into camera i may
need to make this protected
um over here what i'll do is i will
basically just set the projection which
i should call this projection matrix i'm
not sure um we basically just want to
set this to
glm author um and then this
here will be and i'm not sure maybe i
need to include this
um but let's calculate the aspect ratio
first so aspect
ratio equals width divided by height
let's just make them floats because
otherwise it's not really going to work
it's going to be an integer division
then let's do near and far we know
um so author width we'll say
oh no we need author left
so author author left will be 0.5 times
uh aspect ratio times
uh author size
negative okay um
and i think that i think i want to write
this
in reverse just for clarity minus ortho
size times aspect ratio times 0.5 does
that make sense i think it does
um and then author right is obviously
going to be the same
but it's going to be positive and then
author bottom and also
top is going to be the same without the
aspect ratio
there we go and then obviously ortho
bottom should be negative okay
so that is our um orthographic matrix
calculated from a single size variable
based on the aspect ratio of the
viewport
so now that we have all of that we can
just simply say
um author left
author right ortho bottom
ortho top uh
orthographic near orthographic
far look at that that is meaty
um so let's maybe
move that here
we'll do that um
now i might need to include i don't know
if that's in like matrix
transform or some weird thing
gtc matrix transform
that seems to include it okay cool um so
there we go so
now we have kind of a little bit of a
dilemma though because not only do we
have to set orthographic we also have to
set the viewport size because it's
useless without that
so this is where it's important to
basically say that okay if you've
created a scene
and a scene is obviously tied to some
kind of frame buffer you're rendering
the scene to a frame buffer or to a
viewport or to somewhere
if you're doing that you need to make
sure that if the scene
updates the scene cameras update
so what i'm saying is that you can call
this whenever you like
but you need to make sure that you set
the viewport size before you render
now in hazeldev i'm actually doing it a
little bit differently i'm actually
setting this before we render
so if we ever meant if we have a main
camera before we start rendering from
that main camera
we just we just update the matrix every
time
no matter if there's been a resize or
not we'll do things a bit differently in
this version of hazel though
we'll say that only upon resizing
uh will we actually update the camera
matrix and this was one of the things
that twitch chat decided
so what we'll do but i ultimately agree
so what we'll do
and the reason i agree actually is
because instead of just doing it for the
main camera which is what the hazel dev
system is doing
if we have any number of cameras that
should be tied to the viewport size
they will all be updated upon the
viewport size changing
instead of us just you know setting up
just the main camera
before we draw with it so this is a
little bit better
so what we'll do is inside scene
when we do this viewport resize thing we
ultimately need to get the camera
component
well we need to get the camera we need
to get the camera from the component and
then call
on or rather set viewport size on that
camera
now that's not going to work at the
moment because it's not a same camera
but we will change it to be that
so set people's size and then obviously
width and height
so for all of our cameras now this will
set the viewport size accordingly and
everything will work now you need to
make sure though that whenever you add a
new camera to the scene
it gets that event so this is also
slightly
tricky in a way and we'll explore this
in a minute
but what we'll do is what was i going to
do going to go to components
and then change this hazel camera to be
a scene camera
so we'll include this is actually in
here
i think so same camera.h this now has
the same camera will update all of this
stuff this takes in a particular
projection matrix i don't think we want
that anymore because
again we shouldn't really be dealing
with that at least not yet not at the
moment
so we'll just keep it nice and simple
like this and then
um over here now this should work
so technically speaking if we
run this code and we do some kind of i
don't know something to trigger this
which i think it might get triggered
immediately
then we should be rendering
correctly with a default camera
size here i guess of like 10 right
an orthographic size of 10. the only
place where this isn't going to work
and where it still needs some love and
some work is
if we add a camera when the scene's
already been resized or after the first
frame or whatever
then obviously there's not going to be a
viewport resize event so obviously this
is never going to get set
our projection matrix is never going to
get set so that's also pretty bad now i
do want to quickly
check though to see because this is the
other kind of problem
and i'm not even sure how i yeah this is
again
every time this is why it's nice to do
it every frame before we actually
render because if we do it every frame
we can then we can dynamically
and very easily respond to the camera
parameters changing so if the ortho size
size has changed or if something changes
frame to frame
it's fine because we obviously we just
recalculate the matrix every frame so it
will have
it will be updated to match the new
values if that is the case
obviously in this case we have to be a
little bit more careful with how we
change our camera's parameters because
every time they change
we should change them like we need to
recalculate that matrix um
now that's not that difficult to do but
what it does actually involve
is making sure that we tr we keep track
of
our viewport size which again is
extra stuff that you may not want to
keep track of but if we don't do this
we put width and height which i can just
do
like this if we don't keep track of the
viewports within height
right right now like this way then we
either need to make scene camera a lot
more dependent on the viewport and
update it kind of
uh more often or something like that
ultimately because you know if i
if the viewport size hasn't changed but
i've changed my orthographic size
the whole matrix needs to be
recalculated so i need to get access to
that aspect ratio i guess
instead of people within height we could
just keep track of the current aspect
ratio of the camera
that might be better just because
there's a single float let's try doing
that actually
because that that should be enough to
recalculate everything so
we'll say m aspect ratio equals that and
then i'll cut these out
instead of having a local variable um
and then obviously when we do set
orthographic we ultimately want to
recalculate
that matrix so what i'm thinking is
we add a private function called
recalculate
projection
i don't know why i made that const um
i'll recalculate projection and that's
going to do this
and then obviously viewport size is just
going to set aspect ratio
and then recalculate projection um
we could check to see if they're
different and only do it if they're
different but i'm not going to bother
with that
uh set orthographic is going to
recalculate the projection as well
i don't know like you probably want to
like you you might want to have like
various parameters here such as you know
set
orthographic size set orthographic near
far i'll leave that out
now i think this video has been going on
for quite a while so it's probably no it
hasn't been too long
i was going to say so it's probably time
to end this but um we'll keep going a
little bit more
to finish this up so what we will do
now is and of course i'm completely lost
now
um yeah so we've done a lot of
recalculate projection stuff so we
should be able to
um hopefully go back to editor layer and
actually set up our camera entity to do
the proper thing
so over here where we create this camera
component we give it a matrix is this
even going to work because it shouldn't
right
oh no there is um
is this coming from i don't think it
will work i mean i shouldn't work
i'm just verifying
yeah okay there we go so add camera
component it's not taking a matrix very
kindly
so what we can do is we can add that
camera component
i think by default what will happen is
um well actually let's do this
we have defaults for everything so we
can just recalculate the projection and
as long as we recalculate the projection
well it's going to set up the matrix
so we should be just able to add a
camera component do nothing
just do that right and it should work
and it should also respond to the
viewport size everything should be
magical
let's run this and see if it is magical
i'll be impressed if it is because i
feel like i've forgotten a million
things
all right here we go here we go well we
see something
that's great does resizing work
it does i'm very happy that it does and
if we switch cameras well presumably we
did switch cameras no way to tell
so let's actually uh try and change the
yeah what's going on here let's try and
change the orthographic size
um in fact you know what since we're
having such fun here
let's also um let's do this
uh so we'll do float um get
orthographic size cons to return
orthographic size
we'll also do a set orthographic size
float orthographic size
first size orthographic size equals size
um
not const obviously and it should be
void and then we'll also do
our little recalculate projection so
this
is just a little thing that we can do to
make this a little bit easier for us so
we'll recalculate the projection
if we set the size and we're actually
getting we're actually making a getter
and setter for that so that we don't
have to
um necessarily call set you know
orthographic every time
so what we can do now is we can go into
um so we've got the check box here which
is fine
let's do i am gui
drag float i'm going to drag floats
we'll call this
so we'll do this for our second camera i
guess so second camera blah blah blah
blah blah blah okay
so second camera um
how should i do this maybe second camera
get component
camera because i don't want to get that
all the time so auto camera equals the
second camera blah blah
drag float second camera ortho
size long long label
um and we'll basically say so float
author size equals camera get
orthographic size
we'll do um author size here
and if this if this changes so we'll do
if
then we will say camera dot set
author orthographic size
to ortho size so now we should be able
to control that second camera's
orthographic projection
size and i'm getting excited
okay so we see that it has a size of 10
if we switch on
to camera b and i start resizing this
i'll check that out we can go negative
which is a bit dodgy
but you can see that i can change that
orthographic size i can flip back to
camera a if i want to
and obviously if we resize or if we do
anything here
this will in fact stay the right size
let's go back to camera b
let's make this a bit smaller and uh
yeah you can see resizing
definitely works so that is the next
step in our camera system journey
hope that you guys enjoyed this video
let's bring back twitch chat
and this main camera so if you did
enjoy this video please don't forget to
hit the like button if you're on twitch
you can follow the channel
um i'll leave a link in the description
below to the actual twitch stream if you
guys are interested in
joining that um i think the scheduling
for these actual game engine series
episodes is a little bit all over the
place
but um it's uh you know
i i do have if you there's also a
schedule that you can have on twitch now
so if you go to twitch or tv for
the channel schedule any time streaming
usually i'll add
like a i'll add an entry into that
schedule along with like what the
stream's about
so if you're interested definitely check
that out if you want to help support the
series please don't forget to check out
patreon.com where you will get access
to a whole wide variety of amazing perks
such as access to hazel dev code
where i'm currently building a little
mario style game
in 3d with like 2d physics and stuff um
and also live streaming that and i think
i'm going to start live streaming that
for everyone on twitch
pretty soon so pretty exciting stuff
don't forget to help support everything
that i'm doing
thank you all for watching and i will
see you next time goodbye
[Music]
you